okay good morning I think we're on the
air now sorry I'm a minute late today I
want to talk about first of all so we're
doing this 90 day challenge and I'm
doing these eyelids workouts and trying
to find them you know how to make the
best use of this time the goal of these
is to interact with people who are also
doing the 90 day challenge talk about
some of my experiences the thoughts that
I have things that I do on Linc
sometimes I share my screen and show you
the different things that I do and I'm
not sure which is you know what people
are most interested in in doing I have
the impression that the
question-and-answer period is is a the
greatest interest but I'm happy to you
know with this technology that we have
you know share the screen show you what
I'm doing and stuff like that but I was
thinking about how you know why do we
bother with the 90-day challenge okay
the 90-day challenge as someone pointed
out you know it's this period of
concentrated effort I mean there's no
question that I'm spending more time on
the language learning right now than I
remember them and particularly cuz I'm
doing two languages Arabic and Persian
and you know and have a free moment
instead of doing something else I you
know worked on my my languages or at
least I go and read I grab my iPad and I
try to read through some content so and
why are we doing this because language
learning changes has changed my life and
it continues to change my life and I
want to point out some of the ways in
which language learning changes our
lives mostly for the better and so and
many of these of course I don't script
them out ahead of time so it comes out
pretty random but so I'm doing my Farsi
Persian and of course when you're doing
a language you start to gain a different
perspective as I now have through my
learning of Arabic I have a different
perspective on the Arab world on the
countries I you know before I wouldn't I
would have
trouble finding the Persian Gulf where
is Oman where is where exactly is out
there somewhere but so you start to kind
of focus in on this area and you hear
those people speak in their own language
and you gain a different perspective and
so now for example through my Persian
learning I've heard haha
Shiraz what's that grapes is a town and
so now through the different content
that I've been listening to so there's
you know the cities of Iran and I start
to put that on the map by others to Iran
that is Shiraz there's this fahan
there's Persepolis Takht Jamshid
in Persian Maha Maha ad and Isfahan
Tabriz something company he's okay there
Azuri so then I decided to go to Google
and because I'm kind of curious a series
there's a series and Iran is a series in
Azerbaijan and then up pops YouTube
videos of people speaking as they're a
Turk talking about it just so happened
that video that popped up was on the
acceptance of homosexuals in Azerbaijan
so when you hear these people talking in
Oz area and it sounds a bit like Turkish
I have no idea how neutrally
comprehensible it is with intelligible
it is with Anatolian Turkish meanwhile
my wife is what King on Netflix watching
his Turkish soap opera endless endless
complicated stories within stories and
because I would love to be able to watch
this and understand some of it so I had
a peek at Turkish in link I found there
were a few words that were like in in
Persian like SOT pronounce it but that's
our time there was a few others I can't
remember what it was but there are so
there's gonna be some common words from
arabic and and persian in turkish I'm
looking forward to learning Turkish and
when I do I'll have a
different perspective on Turkey and
Azerbaijan or for that matter Turkic
language speakers maybe I have no idea
how close those languages are to Uzbek
or Bakir or Tatar or killed either
whatever I don't know but if I have
Persian Turkish and Arabic I've got a
whole swath of areas through sort of
Middle East Central Asia where I can now
start to have a better sense of those
countries and there's no question when I
seen all these unilingual politicians in
the english-speaking world whether it be
the Brits negotiating a brexit or
whatever they're doing there or you know
the Americans negotiating with or
dealing with other countries if they're
you know if Prime Minister Abe a speaks
English he has a better perspective in
his dealings with Trump than Trump has
of eBay and his Japanese world so when
you speak these languages you gain a
perspective a broader perspective that
doesn't make you a better person however
it just gives you the advantage of this
broader perspective which is
tremendously useful and so in that
regard I was very impressed to see that
one of the Democratic candidates this
mayor Pete Buddha jej
I saw him speaking Norwegian I saw him
speaking Italian and apparently he
speaks a dari which is a form of Persian
and Arabic because he served with the US
Army and half the other style or
something I don't know I don't know all
the details but that gives him a certain
perspective so I think a very big
advantage of learning languages is that
it broadens our perspective as a human
being living in a world where thousands
of languages are spoken there is a vast
array of cultural experiences and
attitude and stuff and through the
language we gain a better understanding
of these and I think that is a big big
advantage of language learning now there
are other advantages and I have I
mentioned my book that language the
languages that I speak
gave me tremendous sort of career
advantages and and the reason for that
is very simple and that is that to be
successful in life you have to take
advantage of opportunities and the more
opportunities that you can attract to
you the greater the likelihood that you
will find an opportunity that really
works for you and if you the more
languages you speak
the greater the greater the variety of
opportunities that can come your way
just expand the range of opportunities
that can come your way it doesn't make
you a better person and speaking the
languages it doesn't guarantee you a job
and people always say you know what job
can I do with my languages and I always
kind of say well you kind of keep them
in the background that's your ace in the
hole you don't have to begin by saying I
speak five languages but if you have
that it gives you a sense of confidence
it gives you advantages that will
materialize at some point and you never
know quite when so certainly to me
languages changed my life I would not
have had you know whatever success I had
in business was very much dependent on
my ability to speak Japanese to connect
with business people in Japan at a
variety of different levels not just
athletes or international trading
company level but there are many offered
many situations were when I started my
own company we were dealing in Germany
we were dealing in Spain we were dealing
in Sweden I really didn't do any
business in China but I've made a lot of
good Chinese friends in Vancouver and
which have enriched my life so but so it
helps you in terms of getting a
perspective it helps you professionally
but now that I'm in my 70s by the way
the seventies is a good decade you know
inevitably being down here in Palm
Springs I watch the TV and I watched the
whole political scene in the US people
in their seventies seem to be punching
above their weight you know we got old
Trump an old Biden and
old Sanders and old Pelosi everybody's
old so you know I always remember when I
had I think I did a video on whether age
affects our ability to learn languages
and someone said yeah but you're too old
you can't learn and so I went back and I
said so what do you consider to be old
and the person replied forty-four years
old I guess for some people for years
old and I've always state if that age
has no impact on your ability to learn
you simply have to activate your brain
cells and you force that level of
activity and exposure and connections
between neurons and our neurons we know
or remain plastic and so we continue to
learn as long as you want so this takes
me then to the way language learning has
changed my life say over the last 10
years because I've put more effort in
the language learning in the last 10
years than at any time previous and that
is this I find it easier language
learning makes me healthier because if I
feel reluctant to go to the gym or go
for a run or have a workout but or
whatever I say to myself but you're also
gonna be listening to your language in
other words the time that I can spend
working out is language learning time
and and you know I can't we'll do
another video you know about listening
listening is the key this thing is so
important listening gives us the
repetition we're hearing things over and
over again and we need repetition in
order to learn but listening can be done
anywhere you know as I've said before if
I'm gonna if I have dedicated study time
I'm gonna read save links and do that
kind of thing
I might even consult our new grammar
resources which you'll find in link
under your profile they don't exist for
all languages but they exist for a lot
of languages just quick review ok and
then so those are my dedicated study
activities but most of my language
learning activities is just plain
listening because I can do it anywhere
and it doesn't matter if you fade in and
fade out and I can listen to the same
stuff
and over again and I say I focus on
different areas and I reinforce
different things or rediscovery
different things and if I couldn't do
that I would not have learned whatever
it is nine languages over the last ten
years no way if I had to rely on sitting
in front of a computer or sitting in
front of the TV watching a video or only
reading a book I would never have
achieved it it's 75 percent of my
learning time is just plain listening
so therefore studying languages
encourages me to do more in the way of
my daily you know physical exercises
another thing is I would in the past you
know I would put off cleaning up the
garage I certainly would be reluctant to
you know do the dishes and clean up
after every meal as it is right now I
make breakfast in the morning I clean up
after breakfast I clean up after dinner
my wife makes me a lovely dinner and and
that I vacuum I mop the floor because
all of these activities can be done
while listening so because you know I
can't just sit down and listen to me
it's just feel I have to be doing
something else together with a listening
so if I have something constructive to
do that allows me to listen at the same
time then I tend to want to do that
activity so language learning has made
me more fit and more helpful around the
house so those are some of the ways in
which language learning has changed my
life and I'd be curious to hear you know
what some of your experiences have be so
with that I will now turn to the quick
comment and but feel free to talk about
anything you want and we'll see we got
here all right just a second okay
Swedish the easiest category one
language for someone who only speaks
English you know I would think so
Swedish is deceptive the word order is
very similar that caught the grammar is
not as complicated as German I don't
know much about Dutch
but there are aspects of pronunciation
in sweet that are difficult hello sir
min student good morning okay trying my
English listening I'm living in San
Francisco but I'm still study I'm not
good enough in English yeah I'm not good
enough okay I really mean it's not don't
tell yourself that you're not good
enough whenever we feel good about
ourselves we are encouraged we feel good
you can control your mood to a large
extent so the issue
[Music]
if better in English this is read Arabic
the issue is are you better than you
were so there was a time when you
understood zero English so you are
improving
nice that because it's important that we
maintain the sort of positive attitude
is your electric way not good don't
understand steve is a 30-day trial as
long enough to make a lasting impact
when beginning to start a new language
that you plan on return so okay 30 days
is 30 days okay a new language 30 days
is not a lot not a lot I really think 90
days three months kept entry
unless for example like I had the
experience of learning Romanian but
there's 70% words there that are easy
identifiable from Italian but and even
at that if I had if I met someone today
when I meet someone in Rumi
when Arbit in Romania so you want to get
yourself past a certain level and I
think three months is a minimum ah see
what do you think about translation is a
good or bad idea when it comes to
learning vocab okay you know I don't
understand the question
obviously we're translating we have to
refer whatever we're learning we kind of
refer to something we know so when I'm
reading a text in the new language I'm
looking up words and I see the trance
I may not be completely relevant to the
context but it's a hint as to the
meaning I have to refer to something I
know so and in the early stages of
learning a language were mentally we're
translating everything and as we get
we're comfortable the big advantage
so the gradual process of relying less
and less on translation if that was the
meaning of the question
learning is constant deliverance yes I'm
not studying any but regarding
administers I do think they would pre
useful for likenesses like in Turkish
yeah the ministers I would like to get I
would like to get advanced mini stories
so here's the deal
you know the 60 minute story what we did
is I found someone online to write those
60 stories she's actually a Canadian
language teach image teacher in Japan I
think she did a great job
so that's 60 now if anybody out there
like there's an endless number of
stories that we could create along the
same pattern in other words the same
story written in two different tenses or
two different persons followed by
questions and answers so lots of
repetition of vocab and that's the
fundamental problem in many sort of
beginning texts there's not enough
repetition of the vocabulary within the
lesson itself now if there are people
out there who are prepared to write
stories along the same model in their
native language and record them and
translate them into English then we will
take those and then have them translated
and recorded in all of these languages
but we need to start with a story
so you know if anybody wants to send me
an email Stephen ENCOM with 10 stories
it doesn't have to be a hundred you know
ten stories
at an advanced level interesting
subjects but where the same pattern of
repetition exists in your language but
with the translation so that we can then
take those and replicate them in other
languages so that we can then continue
and we just added on will say now regard
you know
61 to 70 71 to 80 and in fact if we get
these stories based not on English the
stories that we have are based on
English translated into other languages
if you keep them in other languages
we're gonna have a greater variety of
subject matter greater variety of
structure so I would ask you to do that
and then I will undertake to get them
translated and recorded into other life
so the government all like this there
you go that was from a sweet is thin and
Germano file and I'm not sure if I
remember whether your native language
Swedish you're finished but if you could
do it in one or the up at a gentleman
john KR who is a native speak greek took
an interest so let's see if we can get
that to happen oh yeah here we go john
KR hello Steve I love your work thank
you and blah blah blah blah blah I can
link tutors make private mini stories
for a learner of course they can link
tutors can make private many stories or
they better still like why not share
them with the community unless they have
some they're interested in selling them
or something but share them I mean every
session I have with my tutor I get my
report with the audio recording so
that's three four minutes of the
vocabulary that I struggle with in the
lesson
however the prop only flows is that
there's not enough repetition so I find
it difficult to remember a lot of that
ideally we could ask the tutor to make
many stories based on the vocabulary
that we talked over that's again
difficult to do I think it's better if
we can get our men our our link tutors
our members to make up mini stories
bah-bah-bah I wonder if you've seen the
announcement of the large rare Persian
language
like with you
but online I I don't I will Google an
and see what I can find
but again I'm still at an early stage in
person so I don't if rare Persian
language manuscripts is gonna help me in
my language right I would say that F for
something later ah
and for some talents might replace
language translator jobs but learning
languages often improve your brain
function it's a good happy to have I
agree do you find the type of language
used in professional studies varies from
that which using casual settings to the
point it seems a slightly well I think
we can overdo these differences
obviously Japan is one of those
languages will where there is a
significant difference between the
surgery
- about regular more formal
communication and a more casual but it's
still part of a continuum and and you
know I might have a formal business
discussion
and then we go out in the evening for
dinner or for a couple of drinks and
then the conversation becomes more
casual so you kind of need it all it's
certainly not a different language and
in order to get better at one or the
other you just have to find content in
that style so in the case of Japanese if
somebody wanted to do casual
conversations in Japanese because as we
could have slang and for frenchers
language Chinese then transcribe them
then we can use that as learning
material to improve in those aspects of
language because again the listening is
the most powerful learning activity
liberates you to learn wherever whenever
you are what we need though is to have
the content created so that after
listening we can then go and read and
save words and get a sense about what's
there and listen to it again
main the main activity certainly interns
the amount of time we spend I think is
always listening
I think that our hands are gonna make
anyone a will study I love that popped
up on me communicating I saw polygons
won't be a job advantage at one level
possibly possibly but but don't forget
John Kay are a big part of wide language
language the knowledge of language just
helps you in business is not occurs you
can sit in the forum
and hear what the other person is saying
it's because you can go out after that
meeting and establish close sort of
personal social contact with people
sitting with native speakers of that
language and participate in the social
event okay and to that extent knowledge
of languages remains important and this
remains a way of making sure that more
opportunities come your way at one level
or among
after actually maintain the language
without a trusting easily uh quite high
quite high like I mean you it's gonna be
rusty it's gonna rocks and when you
start to use it again you'll be rusty so
if I look at my statistics at link I
have 60,000 words in check but I would
struggle to speak chat today however
within a few hours I'd be back to where
I was and I'd probably end up better
because there's all kinds of research
that shows that things that we learn
forget learn forget we learn them better
in the end and so leaving something and
coming back to it is a good idea but
don't expect to get right away back to
where you were to be able to do that
you'd have to have spoken a lot it's not
only just the word count in order to be
able just I got to speak French sure you
know Japanese without batting an eyelash
but Russian little more difficult and
check would be a lot more difficult even
though I have a high word child so my
man Steve Sophia you're always here okay
at a point where you have a large
passive Bulgarian land
or listening is more valuable well again
if I look at my own experience I can be
listening just to enjoy the language so
I can listen to Ukrainian Russian I
understand it hard word maybe that I
don't know but and that's refreshing and
so if I know that I'm going to be
invited on to Mandarin Chinese
television in Vancouver
then I will listen to some stuff just to
get the brain you know
finally you know activated a bit but and
then the reading that I do like could be
different kinds of reading I could just
grab a book and read in Chinese just for
fun or I listen to something that I
didn't fully understand and then I go on
I wanted to read that and see what it
was about missed so III can't ask that
question oh okay they Steve Allen right
now he goes I don't see myself doing
other stuff but education is new
restaurant when it comes to earning
money annually what piece of advice do
you suggest for me
you know you can't you can't say you
know give me a job because I speak these
languages I haven't seen that work very
often but as I said hurry the more
languages you speak the broader your
perspective a broader range of
opportunities will come your way you
still have to have other skills you have
to be obviously reliable worker you know
deliver a mic you say you're going to do
all these other things that you have to
have some other skills you can't just
sit languages give me a job
Steve Salaam alaikum yes I resist
indifference in Spanish one time when
Jamie and I ran nine kilometres yeah
okay it's a sloppy sloppy why he also
agrees yeah yes yeah Eric makes a good
point here that that the success that we
can achieve in learning a language also
makes us confident about our ability to
learn other things
Giovanni says I just started off using
nature he helps me to an improvement I
regret oppression is it possible to
learn something tennis thing more than
one language
well it's something that I'm struggling
with right now I'm doing both Arabic and
Persian uh I don't think I'd do it again
because you know justice I really get to
my say Arabic then because I'm doing 3-4
days at one and C for news of another
then I have to go off and do the other
and it means I mean right now I'm
spending a lot of time I'm living but
otherwise if at my normal pace its I
wouldn't be getting enough of the one or
the other I think I would rather focus
online learning a language taught me
that you can reach proficiency in a task
if you just spend a little bit of time
every day practice consistence is the
key yeah and do you use any English to
explain the specific things you would
like them to do for you the question is
first time you talk to a new tutor do
you use any English to explain I tried
to avoid using English if my life and
which skills are so poor that I might
very well expire in English you know as
I'm starting in the language do you have
a story or an example of someone who
learned amazing Spanish from
zero I don't when you have conversation
with the tutor what time of the day view
prefer I tend to do that at 10:00 in the
morning here because then I'm free for
the rest of the day don't forget I'm
tired uh in help with my conference at
various times I thought it would no no I
feel I can do whatever I want
bah blah in Russian there are sometimes
called my first steps after Russia
there's a translation English can see
his new Russian who were currently is it
possible to fix it if you could send us
an email
actually we should remove who those but
we can't go in and fix it what what leaf
does link cannot I I don't think we have
an algorithm which determines whether
this is a word in the language what I do
is I just simply expose we have the
ignore button so you just have to go
through that the first time you study it
any non Russian words you ignore them
they will no longer be counted in your
you know word code that's what I do
there are texts that have the odd
non-target language word I'll just
ignore them and they're gone okay
no Stevie I thought about my other lures
yourself if you're 34 great is you gonna
stop okay there's another focus buddy -
hey Sam I did my teeth okay
effortless Hitler German Sundays he
feels he's making progress some days he
doesn't perfectly normal
first of all some days are better than
another days some you know some time of
the day or two might inspire us more or
make us feel more comfortable and second
of all I think we we continue to make
progress even if we don't notice it and
that is why we have the statistics a
link to remind you that you have
acquired all these words you have been
active you have been listening and
activity equals progress there is no way
that the brain won't learn if you give
it enough listening and reading in and
it will learn and if you open that page
you see fewer and fewer blue words more
and more white words so I think it's
very important to give yourself credit
for what you have achieved even if at
times you struggle to understand and you
struggle to express yourself what
Russian music may be positively
recommend I'm tryna learn Russian as
opposed native speakers well first of
all as a Polish native speaker you have
a tremendous advantage because all of
them mysteries of Slavic languages are
not a problem to you in my own case I
started with our beginning of a material
that link then I went to because there's
and this is ten years ago but I got
audio books in Russian and the Russians
they're very good at my theater a movie
audio books they do a great job and
there's lots of them and you can find
you either pay for the e-book if it's a
modern book or you know you can find the
19th century you know Tolstoy Turgenev
whatever and import them Italy that's
what I did and I also did a lot of
listening to economists agree which is
somewhat controversial in Russia because
it's a somewhat sort of dissident type
radio station but if it has the super
advantage of everyday offering ten or
more interviews dialogues on a variety
of subjects we're always the audio and
the transcript is available
for now so that was a major source of my
Russian learning I should point out that
I did the same for Povich because I went
and bought from poo poo Blio dot pl I
bought audiobooks for weeks the e-book
was available and I imported those into
link and so that's what I used to listen
to music I'm not such a baby but you can
go and find the Russian songs online if
they have closed captions you can then
import those in the link to stubby I
think language learning is like
mechanics ok so funny let's fix 500
cards are better than mechanic and
someone who's read 500 books on fixing
cars ok whatever that's sure logical oh
the only thing I would say with this
mechanic thing is that you have to you
know the passive sort of listening and
reading actually brings the language
into you and you have to have that
vocabulary and that familiarity with the
language before you can start speaking
and so I don't agree that it's like a
mechanic I think it has very little to
do with mechanics would you consider
commissioning professional writers for
stories from multiple countries yes I
would like we commissioned this woman in
in Japan Canadian teacher there so Vadim
a send me a proposal you know I'm
assuming that vanina's is Russian you no
wonder it
um stories written in say Islamic
languages I would like to see them
focused on some of the problems in in
Slavic languages like verbs of motion
aspect
you know we could have won one story
that was all in the survey imperfect
aspect on the next remand the perfected
aspect or different verbs of motion so
that we could kind of zoom in on some of
these aspects of Islamic languages that
cause trouble and if we got them in
Russian then we could easily translate
them into Ukrainian polish Czech and
they would also begin with the same
grammar issues steve adlink comm if
anyone wants to send me an email
okay sandy moonstone thank you and get
all my messages and she's a 64 year old
Meg or an American
hello Steve I've been saying this for
four years and I've been playing Shaco
ha
that's great yes I invited digit rabbit
from going there and speaking a language
really changed my life thank you
very interesting yes and and if you went
there and didn't speak Japanese even
though you play the shakuhachi which is
a flute you wouldn't have enjoyed it as
much so and it's so it changes us as
people okay Eric Eric talking about the
English work birds in the Russian text
like what I don't see not you could but
it makes more sense for the learner
because if Philly if the English is
there if that's not a good lesson then
you should remove it from the library
but if it's a useful lesson actually we
don't want non-target lens worthless we
don't want it so following up on Eric
and John kr can let us know these
lessons the only thing we can do is
eliminate the lesson let's take it out
of the library or if you find a lesson
useful
okay so here's that dancing dancing says
is memorizing by heart you know text a
quick way to learn languages or a
shortcut I don't do it it may be it may
be that it's a good thing to do you know
we have to be selective in where we
spend our time I tend to do those things
that I enjoy doing because that means
I'll continue to do them if there are
formal memorizing of text is not
something that I would enjoy doing I'm
unlikely to do it more than once I think
it would be a painful thing to try to do
and of course there are so many words
and so many sentences and so
this is so the time we spend trying to
memorize one text is time we are not
spending exposing ourselves to a lot of
text so I am NOT a fan of memorizing
texts but some people maybe there's
research that says it's a good thing to
do it's not something that I would like
to do and I think it would limit the
amount of content that I'm exposing
myself to and bear in mind as well that
I spent so much much of my time
listening so to some extent this
repetitive listening is achieving the
same but I don't have to force myself to
memorize everything also even if you
memorize something you're gonna forget
okay I have some books with no audio
is using your computer voice okay it's
okay it's just hard to listen to it's
okay
nothing wrong with it it helps to remind
you how those words are pronounced but
again remember my focus always is on
listening and I think if I were
yeah
artificial voice text-to-speech I
wouldn't want to do that anymore so
again it comes back to doing things that
we find enjoyable so that we're more
likely to continue doing here's a fine
I've been living in the US for six
months and reading and listening
comprehension I include my grammar
because I can understand about
hysterical speak correctly yeah it's
difficult to speak correctly you have to
develop hats for this on phrase if
you're using links say phrases you might
occasionally review the grammar but it's
difficult to remember the explanations
it's difficult to apply goals you
actually have to develop habits and if
you think of the language in terms of
phrases you're more likely to get the
grammar right then if you try to
remember rules it's the same as when I
studied Chinese uh if I remembered if I
tried to focus on phrases I had a better
chance at getting the tones right than
if I tried to remember
the individual tone for each word while
speaking how do you memorize words do
you keep a list the words I don't
memorize words I don't memorize I make
no effort to memorize I use late so I
save words I look at words that I
encounter for the first time and that
helps me get through the text that gives
me as the meaning of that word the text
I kind of half understand I listen to it
a few times get back get me a little bit
of momentum I understand a bit more then
some of those words show up again and
again and I gradually get a sense of the
work that's all I do
and I do have my vocabulary list because
every time you save a word at length of
course you are reminded that you have
seen it before because it's now yellow
instead of blue you can go to the
vocabulary page and deliberately review
some of those I tend to do that because
again I get bored doing that and I tend
to stick with things that are easy to do
like listening and that I don't get
bored doing
yeah we good you could delete things
Asian blah blah blah if you could delete
the English translation and write it
like in ministers where you have to
press the translation button okay john
KR send us the story but tell us either
we are not we cannot go into every
language and re-edit and rewrite the
stories we don't write the stories most
we have written our own mini stories if
you would like us to remove these
stories we will do so otherwise I said
yet let you simply ignore the English
from your statistics how do you find the
people you talk to in your podcast
mm-hmm not sure I some of our podcast
link podcast we did go through maybe a
port and find some people to do them in
different languages do you think
Brazilians who study Spanish from
scratch start with v1 absolutely I mean
Brazilians studying Spanish have already
got 98% of the vocabulary so once they
figure out how the pronunciation changes
I mean it's it's dead easy the biggest
problem that the Portuguese speaker has
is to try to force themselves to get out
of the Spanish you know cocoon and so
when speaking the language to try to
actually pretend the Spanish speakers
because the the great tendency is to
sort of hang back in their own
pronunciation the same is true for
Spanish speakers learning Portuguese do
you ever cheat and study Arabic on a
persians ever vice versa no I mean it's
just the crossover day will change so
the director also over on Tuesday do a
crossover on Wednesday it tends to be
dictated by when I have a cuter lined up
I don't like going into a tutor session
cold so I'd like to have one day to warm
up before I start talking too much
I wonder if I can ask you and take your
opinion about this my anything is my
country Saudi Arabia classified Arabic
as a superior language which I refused
you know what this is from rose when I
was in Morocco trying out my standard
Arabic on a taxi driver he said to me
you are very lucky that you are learning
Arabic because Arabic is the only
language you can use to communicate with
God highly unlikely
now I happen not to be religious but so
I have no opinion on the existence of
God or non-existence of God but if there
is a God
likely that God only in order to believe
that you have to be very closed-minded
the idea that one language is superior
to another is also an example of a very
closed-minded attitude every language
works every language allows people to
communicate in my experience in the
different languages that I speak or at
least understand host:20
all line teachers are able to express
the same ideas all the great works of
literature can be translated into all
other languages some languages have some
neat little expressions or things that
are unique to that language that's fine
that's their individuality but all
languages are equally valuable thank you
for the question yeah I often get that
like anyway I the number of people say
our like languages the riches our
language is the best our language is
that is that no I don't believe that I
have been using name for a little over a
year I've managed a lot of mini stories
now what do you recommend for the next
step okay which language you know that's
the very difficult question for me to
answer I can do one time it you know
pass the many stories I look for other
items in our library but very often I
simply Google I might go to Google
Translate if I I can't say what I want
to say like Polish history or something
or Persian history
so I'll translated Persian history
podcast probably doesn't exist but I
would google it and see what comes up so
you have to there you have to become a
little bit creative
how often do I live stream I during this
90 day challenge period I've been doing
it to readers a week Monday Wednesday
and Friday 10:00 a.m. Pacific time I
don't know how to share but I can tell
you where these are library books ok
might be every text okay when I watch
movie don't suppose that understand but
with southern I understand why do you
recommend another question should I
continue on stuck Minnie Stern's with
addition well you go to explore on your
own and like I don't use movies a lot if
I don't understand because I don't think
that's as effective as listening and
reading but obviously it's something
better if you can find movies with
sometimes in the in the language and
then you can import it into link
I wouldn't stay in the mini-story strong
get into something else you know I
always go back to the many stories to
refresh and discover things that you
didn't notice the first plan which
Ukrainian cities do you prefer I would
like to visit the country and I know
that soon you'll be de ok well I've only
been that I've been de kere l'viv and
intern MC I have to say I enjoyed l'viv
the most because it's smaller very
lively lots of music street musicians
good food nice atmosphere but cab is
spectacular spectacular historical
buildings st. Sofia but sure enough see
also has mother place I mean they're all
good yeah I don't like to make those
kinds of comparisons I think you know
I'm going good Negro for the first time
I have no idea what Negro is like but an
Aviva's certain lady has been is a
wonderful place to it how long did it
take me okay that's me could be - I
don't know if that's - me but I mean I
haven't sort of Swedish was sort of had
various exposures to Swedish this
difficult time so that do you need
certification to put language here
proficient that on your resume I don't
know the answer that question okay
so John with regard to certification
yeah I think employers like to see
certification but I'm glad to see that
in the case of John McKay are they also
interviewed him because I think that
tells me very quickly
some people are good at right tests in
order to get certification but
ultimately speak to peeking to people by
the way the level of English in Greece
is very high however they did humor me
when I was specially in Crete and also
my hotel in Athens they he word me in my
Greek though you know it's very friendly
country to visit by the way and Crete is
unbelievable
creep between knossos palace and the old
Venetians cities like honey ah and the
countryside and the food and the fish
and the olives and the wine lovely place
of it a lot of people have a certificate
and it will speak oh that's true that's
why I think I think that you know
actually getting people to talk is where
you figure out if they can speak what's
up hey Steve I'm writing got me some
feeling into how do I learn it without
looking at words well first of all I'm
you know you do have to learn the
characters I believe and you just do it
the link way that's what I recommend
because it's very tiring to look words
up in the dictionary but you're gonna
forget them right away as soon as you
close the dictionary and that's why you
need the kind of reinforcement that we
have a link in the unlink can you import
audio and real text version of it first
eg YouTube video ok if with the link
extension you click you open up the
YouTube video if it has closed captions
turned on and you click on the browser
extension and you have a lesson which
will have the text of the video the
video itself and the audio that you can
download and listen to separately
impossible only listening for front
understand who paid for do you listen
read you FARC members anteater do you
okay Charles Paul yeah I'd like to warm
up may not be immediately before
speaking to a tutor but I would like to
have at least a day like right now I'm
doing the two languages I will I want to
have been studying the language the day
before I have a session where the tutor
just so that I'm warmed up
as for the topics typically the good
tutor switches the topics on you and
keeps you talking if a good tutor if the
good tutor senses that you're interested
in something and she will continue to
stay on that subject
once she senses that you have nothing
more to say she'll move to another topic
that's been much guys Oh John was
working treating Chania honey is so
beautiful
it's amazing it's amazing actually you
you come to down by the waterfront there
you got to park your car outside you
walk down and you then they have these
lovely little boutique hotels not
expensive and then you open the window
and you're looking at this phenomenal
they I was very very much recommended Oh
Steve have you got some polygon
inspiration comes along you know got the
long long I became aware of her but but
the realization that that massive input
is the way to learn languages is
something that I came upon upon myself
while learning French and Mandarin the
first two languages that I I really you
know achieved any kind of level in and
study and then I discovered Catalan I
discovered those stephen krashen but
they just confirmed what I had
experienced which family do you find
more difficult at least in the beginning
stage Russian Arabic or Chinese um well
it wouldn't be Russian simply because
the Russian alphabet this early
does parallel the Latin alphabet so
Arabic and Chinese I mean Chinese you
just have to put so much effort into
learning character before you can do
anything but the structure of Chinese is
pretty straightforward like there are no
mysteries in the grammar of
chand Arabic has a fairly complicated
grammar as does Roger the Slavic
languages so different languages are
difficult in different ways are you able
to read novels
I have done more so in Chinese and in
Japanese
do you ever peruse the linguistics of
obscure languages no I have to admit my
interests do not go in the direction of
obscure languages but that's fine but
everyone is interested in in whatever
they're interested in it's just not
where my interests are okay 52 I think
we've gone on long enough I hope that
was of interest to people and look
forward to more of your comments do I
know time I'll know I don't if anyone
wants to provide us with many stories we
will put them all up at link all right
thank you bye for now